five fun physics phenomena number one
have a friend hold a cane out
horizontally for you or another similar
object and putting your two index
fingers together try to place them
underneath the center of mass
when they let go
you will find it doesn't normally work
but
now try putting each index finger at
opposite ends of the cane and then
moving your index fingers in towards the
middle
what you will find is that they always
end up
right under the center of mass of the
cane
you can try starting off asymmetrically
and they will still
end up
under the center of mass
you can try going at different speeds
really slowly
or really fast
but you still end up
perfectly under the center of mass
how does this work
number two the phone flip have you ever
tried to spin your phone if you do it in
this direction it's pretty easy it stays
nicely aligned if you spin it along its
short axis you'll also find it spins
very well
but if you try to flip your phone end
over end like this you can't do it
cleanly
the phone will never flip simply end
over end without also rotating in one of
the other directions
even when i make an almost perfect flip
instabilities grow until the phone
rotates around another axis
why can't
no i still can't do it
why is it so number three you've
probably seen that if you rub a cup on
your hair you can make it electrically
charged and if you bring it close to a
stream of water you can actually cause
that stream to deflect
now usually this is used in chemistry
textbooks as a demonstration of the
polar nature of water water is a
molecule with a more positive side and a
more negative side and so what happens
so you're told is that the water
molecule flips around so the positive
side of the water faces the negative
side of the cup and that is what
attracts the water to the cup
but this is not the real explanation
if you have a uniform electric field
there's an equal force pulling the
positive side towards it as there is
pushing the negative side away from it
and so you can't actually do more than
just turn the molecules you would need a
really really strong gradient in your
electric field to make this work at all
and it basically is just not going to
happen from a cup so why is the stream
actually attracted to a charged cup
that is the question
number four take a piece of your
favorite cereal and drop it into a bowl
of water
then using a very strong magnet try to
pull
the cereal around
isn't that cool so why is cereal
magnetic
and finally five the tea bag rocket take
a tea bag and cut off the sealed end
very carefully
now dump out the tea
form the tea bag into a square column
and balance it on the plate
now light the top of the tea bag on fire
try to light it evenly
on all sides
get ready for takeoff in three
two one
ha
yeah
that is the beauty of the teabag rocket
so why did that happen
so how do all of these phenomena work
let me know in the comments or make a
video explaining any or all of them or
subscribe to the channel and i'll post
the answers next week
i hope you enjoyed those fun physics
phenomena i know a guy who would the
former commander of the international
space station commander chris hatfield
i'm actually hosting live events with
him in late august in sydney and
canberra i am so looking forward to that
now the sydney shows are all sold out
but there are still as of now tickets to
the canberra show so if you want to come
to that check out the link in the
description now chris hadfield actually
wrote a book called an astronaut's guide
to life on earth and i am listening to
it right now as i travel around the
world and it is awesome because it
contains great advice not only for
people who want to become astronauts but
also for everyone who wants to lead a
meaningful life here on earth and you
can download this book for free if you
like by going to audible.com veritasium
or you can pick any other book of your
choosing for a one month free trial
audible is a great service with over 150
000 titles in all areas of literature
including fiction nonfiction and
periodicals and so you can find
virtually anything you want there and by
going to audible.com veritasium they
know that i sent you and they help me
out to continue making these videos for
you for free so i really want to thank
audible for supporting me and i want to
thank you for watching